over the past four decades Star Wars has
spawned plenty of movies animated shows
and video games but live-action
television has always been the one
unconquered frontier in the Star Wars
universe at least until now at Star Wars
Celebration 2019 showrunner and creator
Jon Favreau repeatedly emphasized that
the Mandalorian will be one giant love
letter to the original Star Wars trilogy
and that tribute extends behind the
scenes as well bafreux wants to make
sure the Mandalorian feels like our
first visit to that galaxy far far away
naturally green screens and CGI are
necessary to deliver the Mandalorian on
a TV budget but Favreau says that the
crew is also using puppets animatronics
and special effects makeup wherever
possible for example while the dogfights
in the modern Star Wars films are mostly
computer-generated Favreau really wanted
to make a model of the razor crust to
use during production
well Industrial Light and Magic art
staff were so excited about the idea but
they didn't just make a model unprompted
they went home and built a camera rig in
their garages recreating the hardware
that was used to make Star Wars back in
1977 the end result looks just like
classic Star Wars films you'll see this
is this is done isn't that cool ayuh
limbs staff aren't the only Star Wars
fans who got in on the mandalorian
action either the show's producers
reached out to the five-o first Legion a
group of Star Wars fans who make their
own highly detailed stormtrooper outfits
Lucasfilm has teamed up with the five-o
first before for promotional events but
the Mandalorian marks the first time
that the five-o first has appeared on
screen in an official Star Wars
production all of Star Wars owes a huge
debt to George Lucas after all he
created the thing but the Mandalorian
has some specific ties to Star Wars
maker for one the show is heavily
inspired by the first Star Wars movie
especially the opening act and the
cantina scene however as Giancarlo
Esposito has revealed Lucas's input on
the series goes a lot deeper than that
according to Esposito Lucas actually
contributed some creative ideas to the
show while this
guhh Singh the mandalorian with Collider
Esposito said that jon favreau quote
figured it out with George Lucas himself
and worked directly with him to make
sure the show felt like classic Star
Wars Star Wars and videogames have
always enjoyed a healthy relationship
and the Mandalorian pushes it to the
next level while Jon Favreau and his
team used practical effects as much as
they could to capture the original Star
Wars handmade charm digital wizardry was
key in bringing the Mandalorians exotic
worlds to life but how did that ro and
the actors know what their fictional
locations were supposed to look like by
using a game engine of course video
games software is great at rendering
detailed 3d environments in real time
and the Mandalorian team used that tech
to create digital sets that the cast and
crew could film and see the results in
real time not only did that speed up
production but it let the Mandalorians
creative minds get an excellent read on
what the finished product would look
like and adjust accordingly the results
should speak for themselves
thanks to Boba Fett we knew what a
Mandalorian looked like decades before
we knew anything about them as a people
and the Mandalorian wouldn't be the same
without him Boba Fett debuted during the
Star Wars Holiday Special
and while the rest of the program isn't
worth your time Nelvana Studios animated
short the faithful wookie absolutely is
not only does the sequence make Fett
cooler than the movies ever did but the
design ended up influencing both how the
Mandalorians looked on the Clone Wars it
also set the standard from the
Mandalorians costume that narrow visor
the big ol holster the natural color
scheme and the visible Battle Damage
those are all from his old short it also
gives an idea as to what the Mandalorian
might look like in fact nelvana's
animators look to westerns when
storyboarding the short the faithful
wookies surreal landscapes and the
dinosaur that Boba rides might be a
little too fanciful for live-action TV
but if you want to see Star Wars
reimagined as a spaghetti western you
don't have to wait for the Mandalorians
mere there's already an example out in
the wild if you're worried that creator
jon favreau isn't up to the task of
bringing Star Wars to the small screen
don't be he's got some help longtime
Lucasfilm president Kathleen Kennedy is
listed as one of the show's producers
and all of the material will still go
through Lucas Films story group the
organization in charge of keeping Star
Wars Canon consistent Favreau is also
getting a big big hand from the animated
side of things Dave Filoni may not be a
household name but if you're a
modern-day Star Wars fan you know his
work fellow needed the Clone Wars
feature film and he worked side by side
with George Lucas to bring the
subsequent animated series to the air
Fulani also co-created both rebels and
the newest Star Wars cartoon resistance
in other words he's the guy behind a lot
of the best parts of modern Star Wars
Canon according to the art of Star Wars
the Clone Wars
Fulani is the brains behind Anakin
Skywalker's beloved apprentice ahsoka
tano on rebels bologna and a staff
raised questions about the Jedi's
relationship for the force years before
Rian Johnson and the last Jedi did the
same revenge is not the Jedi way I am no
Jedi heck he even voiced chopper rebels
scene-stealing droid Fulani is serving
as one of the show's executive producers
and he'll make his live-action directing
debut by helming the Mandalorians very
first episode the Mandalorian takes
place about five years after Return of
the Jedi and twenty-five years before
the force awakens making the galaxy a
very different place than what you're
used to the ragtag Rebel Alliance has
transformed itself into the new Republic
a representative democracy that spans
many known planets the Galactic Empire
on the other hand hasn't been as
fortunate after the battle of jakku
brought the Galactic Civil War to a
close what remained of the main Imperial
fleet retreated to the mysterious
Unknown Regions where it will eventually
reform into the first order not yet
though
the first order is still years away it's
a time of transition out on the Outer
Rim where the Mandalorian takes place
former imperial warlords are scrambling
to hold on to power former rebels are
trying to figure out where they've
now that the fighting has stopped
criminals try to profit off the
confusion and the Mandalorians main
characters are all caught right in the
middle of it the Mandalorian isn't even
out yet and it's already a hit or at the
very least Disney seems extremely
confident that it'll be 1 months before
the Mandalorian debuted Jon Favreau got
the green light to start writing season
2 by the time the cast and crew started
making the rounds to promote the first
season filming on the second was already
underway season 2 adds a couple of new
directors to its already stacked lineup
for one Favreau will actually get to
helm an episode or two of the series
this time around during season 1 he was
too busy on Disney's The Lion King to
take a direct role behind the camera the
Mandalorian cast member Carl Weathers
will also direct the season 2
installment in fact his interest in
sitting in the director's chair was one
of the main reasons why he joined the
series Dreamz
[Music]
you're right Carl Weathers Favreau
promises that there are plenty of
surprises and a few old legends
characters in the pipeline don't give up
on the mandalorian when season 1 ends in
December the show is just getting
started check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]